?
"SERNTPE" AN
APPROPATFO
UKRAINIRE
VOLODYR
1 STEW
RECENT S
SH MY NS ARE
VLINME NOW IS HEW BUREAU OHE ."
HE'S CURRENTLY WOR OUT O
ISTANBULHE SHARED THLI OTHHIN, A
CK GIVENWHSIY HACHT TTLE FOR RU
.
THEY HAVE.
AND MANY PEOPLE HAVER LEFT FN, V
.AS SHOT UR AT LEAS THEY SUPPOR
RU T VLADIMIR PUTIN, HETH IF T U
CRIMINAL PROCU AGAINST HEN I TH
>>SO, S TTER
OF FAC T
SLIDA VADAS IS
APPROVAL
HE RTI?
EL CAN
COY AS A WHOLE.CAUSMAIG PIIT'S C
R  -WHRS
ARSOSWERS,
SAY.K  EECHETO
WE SHOD  BE OF EXIST
FOR A LONG H
PRESIDENT TILONGNOW, OF COURSE,.
POLAND MANY  UTED ETEE, ORANEOAN
THINGSAIDS THAT
OPLE.
D INTERVIEWS SHOTHAT
S NOW ACCEPTIN'S
BIBEING BY PUTINBOR HIS OWN PPOT
NG
OF PNE IAIN.HI
WHH  NOT A SOLE OF
BUT WIRNMENTS
NS O
CANALLSSIAG REMOVED INSAID, FORW
FROM RUSSIPEHING IY  AS T
IT'S NARBURUAN TD TO I
UKRAIN JUST D  RUSSIA IS
INGAE GOING E SSREFOSITUATION,
EN
HAS BEEN -
HE HOPEAS BEE
Y SOM.
'S THE
LIST OF THOSE CORPORIO TURNED T
EVERYTCK
McDONALD'S.
NG DOES THATLA'S  SO FAR AS INS
DOIN
KN.
INSTEAD, THEY IGHTS
ANY
.  IKSTOHIN
LY
FELT THE EFFECT OF
F ALOF THESTD
BETHERE'ME
OP
GOD  BASAL
GLOBALIZCOOR 3
THAT. M
RUSS,  COM
TIS TO
T  KIND OF RHE FLAG.
CA YOU DAC ACT. O I
IGSO, BASICALLY,T'A VERYICTABLEM
>>E IT'S LONLASTING,
>>URY HAD
ACCESS